this is my question be great really like
somebody to go further into the concept
of reverse gravity and dark energy
because it seems that as more as
explained about the creation of the
universe there are more head functions
emerging and this is one of the most
recent ones certainly seems to be one of
the most experienced hi Alice so you're
asking what what is dark energy and
reverse or I suppose anti-gravity really
consists of and well the that concept
came out of the observation as you know
that the universe which is expanding is
not expanding at a steady rate but
rather the rate of expansion is
increasing the universe has accelerated
expansion and that's hard to explain
because some people in fact expected to
have found that the universe would DXL
right since matter tends to cause the
universe's acceleration to slow down
gravity is always attractive so if
there's matter or energy it will pull in
and reverse the expansion the
accelerated expansion therefore could be
due to anti-gravity well that's not the
case anti-gravity doesn't exist we
believe what we do believe is and if you
want an X Factor that explains the
accelerated expansion but it's a very
old X Factor it's one that dates back to
the beginning of Einstein's theory of
gravity of gin
relativity in which he understood that
there could be a form of energy that
pervades the universe we call sometimes
vacuum energy is just energy of empty
space that would act in a way like
anti-gravity not so much because of the
energy but because of the pressure of
this stuff the vacuum could it behave
like a gas or a fluid with both energy
and pressure now normal matter normal
fluid has positive energy and positive
pressure and that causes things to to
get attracted and contract but stuff
that Einstein that appears naturally in
Einstein's theory has negative pressure
positive energy and negative pressure
and it is that negative pressure that
actually causes the universe to have
accelerated expansion so that's the
simple explanation of this accelerated
expansion of the universe it's natural
because it's the one form of a kind of
fluid filling the vacuum that wouldn't
be an ether that wouldn't pick out a
preferred observer it's the one form of
energy and pressure of a fluid if you
want to have a substance that would look
the same to all observers ordinary
fluids made of ordinary matter look
different to different observers moving
with different velocities they have
different energy content much like a
automobile has much more energy when
it's moving fast than it does when it's
at rest but this kind of fluid because
it has negative pressure just the right
amount equal to its energy
in magnitude and opposite and sign is
just arranged so that all observers no
matter how fast they're moving would see
the same amount of energy and negative
pressure and therefore couldn't tell
which was the preferred observer of the
preferred frame of reference so this is
the one kind of energy of momentum
allowed in the vacuum pervading the
universe that doesn't pick out a
preferred observer so it's allowed by
the theory we should expect it the
therefore from that point of view
there's nothing strange about this
observation of the accelerated expansion
of the universe and in fact we can test
whether the energy and pressure are
exactly related as Einstein's theory
would predict so that there was no
preferred observer and it works out very
well so they're all as well the only
problem we have as theoretical physics
is to understand the magnitude of this
energy where does it come from we sort
of know that quantum fluctuations and
quantum mechanics the fluctuations of
all fields and particles will give rise
to an energy that pervades the vacuum
but we have no way of calculating how
much energy will be produced and all of
our attempts so far have gotten the
wrong answer so whereas we don't
understand the magnitude of this energy
by any means oh we or at least I am very
comfortable with a phenomena itself and
its explanation